die die die die die die
die Betrayed sieht komisch aus
Lull
ne stimmt doch alles, muss zu gehen
die Tüte Tüte Tüte Tüte Tüte
Tüte Tüte Tüte Tüte Tüte
Moin Shadow Ghost
Ich glaube ich muss mal die Musik ein bisschen leiser machen, müssen wir gleich mal gucken
Moin Leute
So heute spielen wir
Overwatch
Äh, was auch immer das Spiel gerade rumspacken ist, keine Ahnung
Äh, Overwatch ist gerade abgekackt, aber das lag an mir, weil ich komische Dinge rumgeklickt habe
Yeah Mario Kart, ich hab mal eine Super Nintendo Playlist angemacht
nicht immer dieses komische Elektronik gedudel da
düdüdüdüdü, Overwatch nochmal neu starten
So, ich hab mir einen neuen Account gemacht, Overwatch, ich hab irgendwie vorhin übelst Lust verspürt
Overwatch wieder zu spielen
Ich weiß halt nicht wie lange das anhält
die Auflösung stimmt nicht so ganz
Und ich muss mich erstmal wieder, das schreibe ich auch mal in den Titel rein.
Kann das sein, Informationen aktualisieren, dass der denn...
Kann das sein, dass er den Titel nicht wirklich aktualisiert hat?
Der hat den Titel nicht aktualisiert, oder?
Im Titel steht immer noch irgendein Scheiß drin.
Im Titel steht immer noch... TF.
Kann das sein, dass Twitch gerade bugged und Streamtitel nicht aktualisiert?
Kann das sein?
Ich hab, ich hab da, ich hab Overwatch reingeschrieben.
Aber irgendwie... Hä?
Was ist da los?
Nee, Twitch ändert den Titel nicht.
Warum hat Twitch denn den Titel nicht geändert? Ich mach noch mal kurz aus.